bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de ski mag vivront ville
ne signifie pas pollutions nuisances
sonores ou encore trajets interminables
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines fait partie de ces
agglomérations qui innovent pour une
mobilité plus fluide et moins polluant
bus train circulations douces
qu'est ce qui va changer pour les
usagers à la rentrée prochaine pour vous
dit tout c'est pas
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines territoire de
230 mille habitants et où les
possibilités de déplacement sont
multiples en 2014 saint quentin en
yvelines était la première collectivités
franciliennes a approuvé son plan local
de déplacement un plan révisé suite à
l'adoption du nouveau plan de
déplacements urbains de la région ile de
france
objectif d'ici 2020 - de véhicules
individuels plus de transports en commun
et de déplacement en mode actif et la
transformation commencera dès la rentrée
prochaine
à travers l'instauration d'une pluralité
de service ceci afin d'adapter l'offre
de transport qui font bien à chacun pour
un territoire plus facile à vivre et
plus attractifs comme toutes les grandes
agglomérations saint-quentin-en-yvelines
n'échappe pas aux flux des déplacements
domicile travail des flux
particulièrement important ici sur les
146 mille emplois que compte le
territoire 70% sont occupés par des
habitants qui vivent en dehors de
l'agglomération
quand 56 % des actifs saint quentinois
travaillent à l'extérieur du territoire
il y a un vrai besoin d'infrastructures
pour accueillir l'ensemble de ses
salariés au niveau déjà des entreprises
à ont été mis à plat en place un
dispositif extrêmement je trouve
pertinent grâce à l'association delta
qui s'appelle le plan de déplacement
inter entreprises puisque des grandes
entreprises se regroupent et side et de
voilà de proposer à leurs salariés des
moyens de transport
l'agglomération encourage de longue date
le covoiturage sur le territoire
l'engouement des habitants pour son mode
de transport n'est plus à démontrer
dans ce contexte le développement des
transports en commun est primordial la
région investit afin de moderniser les
infrastructures ferroviaires
quant au réseau de bus il devrait
connaître dès la rentrée septembre sa
première phase de restructuration
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a une difficulté sur ce territoire
c'est à dire c'est un territoire sur
lequel nous allons des lignes de trains
qui sont quand même assez vieillissante
et voir sur certaines d'entre elles
défaillante
et vous que pensez-vous du réseau
ferroviaire plus de régularité notamment
sur l'aisne qui va embrouiller il ya
souvent des retards
je prenais principalement le rer c mais
bon maintenant en fin de compte plutôt
des lignes on va dire eu pour au moins
aller jusqu'à versailles et enfin il ya
un petit peu plus de disponibilité fin
de train pour aller après du coup
jusqu'à saint quentin et peut-être un
meilleur accès pour la défense qui est
un peu délaissé par rapport à mon rêve
en invitant sur paris c'est un peu
compliqué donc un c'est que si on est un
petit peu plus des trains ce serait
quand même bien sont plutôt bien
organisés les trajets à s'ils sont à
l'heure il ya des conflits 15 minutes on
sent quand on s'est plutôt que sur le
terrain sur le réseau ferroviaire
d'importants travaux sont réalisés la
région se mobilisent afin de moderniser
les infrastructures des rer c et les
lignes l et une du transilien sur la
ligne n de nouvelles rames devraient
voir le jour à partir de 2021
en parallèle l'agglomération développe
les liaisons de pôle à pôle heureusement
50 ans un réseau de bus qui est très
étoffé et qui va être va l'être encore
plus puisqu'il a été remis à plat à
partir de 2016 pour le restructurer l
agrandir au périmètre des doses que
monde maintenant les saint quentinois
eux ont leur propre souhait pour le
réseau de bus plus de bus dans les
heures creuses en fait j'habite à
villepreux
je trouve que c'est face est bien
desservi par rien de spécifique je suis
satisfaite de la fréquence les réseaux
de bus sont pas assez mis en valeur par
rapport aux nouvelles constructions les
jo il ya des événements des jours fériés
autre tête un peu plus de bus on va voir
un peu la fréquence je sais que ça va
changer à partir de septembre le réseau
de bus représente 20 millions de trajets
par an sur les 65 lignes de la
convention partenariale entre
l'agglomération et ile-de-france
mobilité un réseau performant et
interconnectée avec les territoires
alentours comme versailles des liaisons
ont ainsi été créés vers divers pôles de
la région des lignes particulièrement
utilisés par les usagers
c'est pourquoi l'offre sera élargie dès
le 3 septembre prochain
un questionnaire qui a été fait auprès
des habitants du territoire de saint
quentin des lignes plus directes plus
rapide plus de fréquences aux heures de
pointe ainsi que des bus le week end et
le soir
telles étaient les souhaits des
habitants des souhaits exaucés
dès septembre prochain
[Musique]
le service d aide à l'exploitation et à
l'information des voyageurs sera
également étendu aux arrêts de bus par
le biais de panneaux lumineux mais aussi
sur une application mobile une
application qui devrait s'étendre aux
véhicules individuels afin de connaître
son itinéraire les routes les moins
embouteillé et les parkings disponibles
à l'arrivée et on va arriver donc avec
une très très nette amélioration du
réseau bus et je pense que là ça va être
un vrai plus pour l'ensemble de nos
habitants avec la création bien sûr de
ligne nouvelle qui n'existaient pas et
kiki fortement au caire auparavant on
espère ainsi que réduire un petit peu le
nombre de personnes qui pourront leur
leur voiture pour se rendre à l'égard
pour accueillir ces bus des pôles
garçons créer comme à la gare de la
verrière qui subit actuellement une
rénovation complète
il ya plusieurs projets en un an il y
avait un vrai problème de circulation
entre
elancourt trappe maurepas et la verrière
le matin et le soir donc doublement du
pont fut l'heure il a il a plusieurs
plusieurs vertus un cd de faciliter
cette transition
et puis de faciliter aussi tout ce qui
est bus et à terme il doit être liée
aussi en tcsp jusqu'à la gare de trappes
ça va nous faire une liaison
normalement de qualité facilitant le
transport et transports doux vélos
piétons et à un parking de 750 places
remplacera les deux parkings existants
l'idée aussi 7 2
de favoriser mieux le
le transport collectif en bus et donc de
limiter quand même les places de parking
dans le même esprit des parkings vélos
sécurisé aux abords de la gare
permettront de laisser la voiture à la
maison des dépose minute pour les taxis
comme pour les particuliers seront aussi
créés c'est sûr qu'entre temps il va y
avoir quelques petits quelques petites
perturbations mais je pense que les gens
sont à même de comprendre que certes
perturba sont là d'abord on essaie
qu'elles soient le moins forte possible
et puis ensuite qu elles amèneront à
véritablement en mieux
d'autres projets sont à l'étude dans les
gares de plaisir grignon fils paul et
claire et coignières
[Musique]
autre nouveauté l'arrivée d'une nouvelle
génération de bus 100 % électrique trois
premiers bus circuleront dès l'automne
une première en grande couronne
quatre nouvelles lignes seront également
accessibles aux personnes à mobilité
réduite
portant le total de ses lignes à 27 à
savoir plus d'un tiers du réseau
[Musique]
autre mode de transport le vélo
l'agglomération compte 400 km
d'itinéraires cyclables
le but est de passer de 2 à 4% de part
modale pour ce mode de déplacement et
pour y parvenir
de nombreux services ont été mises en
place sur le territoire et vous le
déplacement à vélo vous l'imaginez
comment pouvoir circuler à 100 sécurité
bien séparée de la route
c'est la continuité parfois ils avaient
été les interruptions peu comme si par
exemple une piste cyclable qui après j
ai plus rien quand je les prends les
trottoirs ou alors une chaussée n'était
pas très pratique de plus en plus la
petite reine pour sa place sur les
abords des routes saint-quentinoise les
services et afférents aussi depuis
décembre dernier la vélostation a ouvert
ses portes en gare de saint-quentin
montigny le bretonneux 170 vélos sont
proposés à la location en longues ou
courtes durées des stationnements
sécurisés sont accessibles aux
titulaires du pass navigo ainsi qu'un
atelier de réparation un plan des
itinéraires cyclables à l'échelle des
douze communes est également disponible
les 400 km de pistes actuelles devrait
bientôt s'étendre des efforts
d'aménagement souligné pour deux villes
de l'agglomération entrée dans le
baromètre des villes cyclables élaboré
par la fédération française des usagers
de la bicyclette terre d'innovation
oblige saint quentin en yvelines se
tournent désormais vers les transports
de demain taxi robots et navettes
suspendu tout est envisageable pour
accroître les services et limiter la
pollution et les embouteillages
un réseau de transport aérien en menant
6 personnes assises et pouvant atteindre
la vitesse de 100 km heure saint quentin
en yvelines étudie la faisabilité d'un
tronçon test de transport innovant le
prt il s'agit d'un projet de navette
électrique autonome suspendu à sa mètres
du sol sur des sur des infrastructures
très légère et qui vous permettront avec
une application téléphonique ou en août
avec dans la station de pouvoir
commander votre navette et d'aller d'un
point a à un point b
ce transport personnel est prévue pour
fonctionner 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur
les temps de déplacement serait ainsi
réduit le coût de fonctionnement et
d'investissement minorée et l'impact
environnemental réduit au maximum le
projet n'a encore jamais été réalisée
dans le monde
mais l'agglomération se propose pour
expérimenter le dispositif de la
start-up supra wales le montage
financier est actuellement à l'oeuvre la
région ile-de-france les entreprises
l'agglomération et des voisins
versaillais pourrait être partenaire de
l'opération
[Musique]
vous savez tous désormais sur vos
transports pour la rentrée à très
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
saint-quentinoise ciao
[Musique]
et